why do athletes make great actors well
some do and some don't what I think it
is
is you're used to competing as an actor
I mean as a as a as an athlete it's
about
competition you're competing whether
you're
competing one of 11 guys on the football
team on offense or one of the 11 guys on
defense or you're running track and
you're individual
or you're running a relay where they
hand you The Paton this
competition and those are all of those
things are part of being an actor too an
actor is like actor is an athlete
basically too
because the relay is part of being an
actor where I have to hand something off
to you or hand the scene off to you or
relate to you or if I'm individual where
I'm on stage doing a
monologue like a runner by themselves or
you know um in in some situation where
you know we're having a dual track meet
I use that example where you have to get
points for the team the same thing as
far as being on stage or being in in a
film or whatever it's a collective and
actors actor athletes tend to
be able to maneuver the
business not that not because they're
better
than than people that aren't
athletes but like I said earlier you
accept defeat
easier because you're not going to get
you're not going to get 99% of the stuff
you go for and in sports you're not
going to win all the time I mean unless
you know if like you you say bat to
somebody you know whatever you know but
that's rare that's rare so you're able
to do that and like I say that's why I
think like I was saying earlier why a
lot of my actor friends or former act
former actor friends that aren't in the
business now who had been coddled and
had done a certain thing can't make it
in the industry even in athletics a lot
of the young guys that are cuddled all
the way up in basketball football
whatever A lot of them don't make it
because they can't
handle the the rejection and
frustration once they get into the arena
a lot of them can it's the same with
acting so when somebody like me that did
it as a kid and got away and came back
and was basically forced into it
because couldn't do anything
else you tend to be able to handle all
of these different things like I said oh
at the beginning I I couldn't handle the
rejection I oh my my my mentor was
like dude you're not going to get hardly
none of this
stuff I mean voiceover
wise I've done this week I think I've
done 10 voiceover jobs
auditions guess how many I
got
zil is not a
thing oh now don't think that I'm like
oh that's okay no no I'm not but I'm
able to just say Okay moving on to the
next one you got to be able to do that
you got to be able to do
that I played Sports and I dropped the I
was one of the fastest guys out there
got wide open the quarterback threw a
long
pass I dropped
it now you got to Stadium full of family
and friends and all kind of
people
oh there's nothing like that it's
like I've been in
plays who have gone up for whatever
reason I couldn't remember
lying and the person in the scene is
looking at me and if they are
experienced actor they'll throw me a
line or they're smart enough to carry
the scene on but a lot of times these
people
are and you both up there looking stupid
I've been
there I was in a scene with a guy who we
did we did a a a a a onea play where we
had to
do a dream sequence where we all playing
cards and both both sequences were dream
sequences where we playing cards and the
other actors that were coming into the
scene off stage had
to react to the
cues he
decided instead of doing the scene in
the first Dream
sequence he made a mistake and did the
lines for the second one so the actors
that were not supposed to come in until
the second scene
you could hear him
backstage
scrambling so myself and another guy who
is a very prominent actor now we said
okay we have to get him back on
track so we went back to the first scene
improv a point and he's up there you
know like looking around and I'm looking
at this guy and I'm saying okay without
me saying anything I I've gone back to
not let the audience know I'm I'm I'm
rewriting the scene to get him back and
he's still
like it happens you know and that's one
of the things I love about Live Theater
oh I love it it's like you know to go up
you know I did stand up comedy I tried I
I could I couldn't do it
because I just couldn't handle
the
pre-show before you get up on stage I
couldn't handle that that's why a lot of
comics they drink or they do drugs
because it's not it's not when you're on
the stage is before you get up
there and and see I took I took a couple
of classes here years ago to do
standup and we did we did the show and
my teacher talked about he said
um if you if you bomb or whatever you
know how to handle that and he even had
to say even though I'm telling you how
to handle bombing when you don't get any
laughs or whatever you still have to
experience that I can't tell you what
that is until you do it and my situation
was I bombed and the audience is like
looking and you they know your you know
when somebody bombs and so what I did
was what I naturally do
as far as me I
said I'm bombing up here aren't I and
the audience
laughed and I started talking about that
I started saying I always wondered what
it was going to be like to get up here
and have y'all [__] excuse my
friends up here watching me bomb and the
audience fell out and my material I had
was gone and for the rest of my time up
there I talked about I said now my hands
and my Palms was sweating and I said you
know I start doing all of that and when
I left that stage they were like and
when we went back to the class my
teacher
said you are
natural I said well I I bummed he says
yeah but you were funnier after you
bombed and you told the audience he says
do you know what it took for you to just
come out and say that I said I didn't
have any choice I said I was
awful I had to talk about
it
but it's just stuff like that you know
which which uh which I think is part of
what I love about this business I love
it because you
[Applause]
know no performance even live or
whatever or take
filmwise nothing is ever the same no no
okay take
one can you do that again we're going to
we had a liting problem here or the uh
or you know the reflector or whatever
you know technical just do exactly what
you did before you know no it's not
going to happen you know you do you try
but it's it's
different